欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。
或者是说它的一个稳定性价值比较高的词去选择。
第一个前提就是产品要和同行爆款产品相似或者同款,也就是你要发的产品一定是要有跟同行相似的款或者是同款的产品才去用这个方法。
如果你的产品跟它都不相不相似或者是也不是同款,那么你去提取它的关键词可能就是会出现偏差,可能就不太适合你用。
接下来我们就来看一下一个超越同行爆款的标题组合的一个流程是怎么样的。
首先第一个我们要找到同行爆品,这个大家都知道怎么去找吗?
在榜单国际站首页的榜单去找到你同行的爆品。第二个就是分析爆品的一个标题,你要去看这个爆款它里面都有哪些核心的词,有哪些核心的词是有流量的,你要去看。
第三个提取部分爆品的关键词,也就是你要在一个爆款的同行的标题中,你要去找到一些比较核心的关键词。
记住,千万不要完全的复制或者是照搬。为什么呢?因为我们如果全部复用它的关键词的话,那么我们所覆盖的
人群和你这个同行的爆品所覆盖的人群是一样的,也就是搜索的这一类人是一样的。这样的话,那么我们就跟它形成了正面的竞争。正面竞争的话,那么我们所要付出的成本付出的直通车成本
就会很大。所以说我们要做部分差异化的竞争。做差异化竞争。也就是我们需要
跟它部分词一样,部分词不一样。因为部分词不一样,那么我们所覆盖的
人
部分人就是不一样的。因为我们
组这个爆款标题的时候,我们是不需要再去悬评的,因为我们已经知道同行的这款产品卖的非常好,我们的这款产品其实
已经不用去再测评了,直接干
使用车
做爆品就行了
最后面一个第四个要结合
一些自己的
去选的关键词
开始
做差异化的标题,也就是
你自己选的词
加上
同行提取的
爆款的标题的部分的词
再等于
你的一个
完整的标题
接下来第六步
那么我们就是把这个产品
进行一个
推广
因为这个这款产品当你确定之后,一般你去组一到五个标题
一到五个标题,然后加入到指动者同时进行一个推广
这个就是一个
组合超越同行爆款标题的一个
完整的思路
那么具体怎么样去做呢,我们来看一下具体的案例
首先
我们一定要注意一个点就是
是提取同行优质的内容,而不是全部复制,一定要
记住这个
原则
我们来看,第一个案找到了同行爆款
下面这个就是同行的爆品
那么找到了之后,我们就去看
它里面有哪些
比较核心的词
是我们值得用的
首先我们来看这个标题,你看前面这些营销词
我们不会用
不用营销词不用看了,这种词都不用
我们在看它的核心词是什么
核心词是这个
短裤
那么它核心词的短裤的话
那么我们提取它有效的词就是
什么跟
这个短裤有组合的,比如说南式短裤跟它有组合的,这个是
也是跟它有组合的,这个是工艺的,也是跟这个短裤有组合的,这个是工艺,这个是
款式
材料,所以说我为什么说
组一个超越同行的标题需要你对
自己本行业的产品的关键词是非常的熟悉
了解的
那么从这个标题中,其实我们就提取了一
二三
就提取了三个核心的关键词
那么三个
核心的关键词你可以用到你的
作为你的
部分的
标,部分标题的一部分
一部分
那么剩下的这一部分你就要去,你看这一部分你是用不了了
那么这一部分你就是用自选词去填补
就可以了
这样的话你做出的标题是不是
跟同行一样的,但是
你还有一大部分
是跟同行不一样的
但是呢
你提取了它的关键词,你要去
关键词搜索指数里面去
查一下这个关键词是否有
搜索
是否有搜索指数,有的就用,没有搜索指数的就不要用了
是这个逻辑
而且我说的提取这个爆品
标题的里面的关键词
并不代表说
你要跟它的顺序是一样的
比如说你看到的这个你提取了,这个提取了,这个也提取了,这个也提取了
你把它完全一样的用在这个
标题的背后
这可以这样用,但是呢,建议就是
你可以跟你自选的词
进行一个打乱
顺序,然后重新排列
重新组一个标题
你只是覆盖了Task
含有的关键词而已,但是你的顺序
跟你的组合
是
有差异化的
所以你要按照这个,而不是升班硬套,直接把它做为你的
标题的结尾
你一定要自己调整
这是第1个案例
第2个案例,我们来看一下,这个是
蓝牙的
这个是它的
核心
产品词,是吧
我们来看,它中间这个标题,你看我画掉了这个
横线的这条
其实就是它的一些
营销类的词,你可以直接把它排除了
这个词你肯定是要用的,所以说这个不用提
那么它提取的是什么呢
你要去分析
这些参数
以及这些
属性的词,你要去
关键词搜索指数里面去搜
你看哪些词它是流量比较大且稳定的
那么你就可以去
提取
这两个框里面的
部分关键词提取出来
然后再去
关键词搜索指数里面去寻找一些
符合你这个款式的
产品
然后再组成
组成一个
属于你自己的产品的
标题
我们再来重复一遍就是为什么一定要做差异化的
首先第1个原来你看别人的产品优质的产品都是
买家都是非常多的那么它的权重非常高
如果你完全样的那个标题你是不是要用直通车去推广
而且你的排名不一定有的好比如说他6块钱一个点滴
你可能12块钱或是15块钱
才得到一个点击
是同样的一个词
因为他权重高与推广名分高那么他的点击成本比你就可能就要用到这12到15块钱所以说成本非常高
所以说你做差异化就是部分是正面竞争部分是
不正面竞争
那么你就通过新增一些
关键词的话那么你就相当于去
新增覆盖另外的一些
人群
就是你的款式已经不用选了
而且是一定是比较受市场欢迎的
所以你这款
这么受欢迎的产品
同行让A人群看到你这款你就让
A+B两类人群看到是不是你的流量很有可能就是你的覆盖的范围要比他的
比同行的
大
是这个逻辑吧
因为
不同的关键词覆盖的人群是不一样的
所以你一定要理解这个逻辑
你才知道为什么我要非要你差异化
做标题
接下来我们来去看一下具体怎么样去找
再详细的
给大家演示一遍
比如说
我们在这里
找到国际站的首页
首页了之后你在这里不是有个等级排名吗?等级排名你点更多
点更多
点更多了之后呢你进来之后下拉
找到你们的内幕
找到你们的
具体的内幕
就直接比如说电子类
你就进去
然后你就看
这里面哪个属性你的产品
你想发哪种
比如说哪个是相似的比如说第1个非常相似你就想发这款
你也有
你就点进去
点进去了之后
比如说这款
跟这款
这款也是
这款也是你看它主图都一样
那么你
把4个链接或者是5个或者是更多的链接打开
打开之后就去一个个去提取里面的关键词
它们很多是不一样的
如果你在多个标题里面提取关键词那么你的
覆盖量就广了
比如说它的核心词都是比如说都是这个
你这个就不用提取了你就
这个标题里面
也提取部分
这个标题也提取部分
比如说4个标题都提取了有效的一些
词组
那么你是不是能够
本身就记掌了很多有效的词
而且这些产品的款式
一定要选
与你相似或者是说与你同款的那些产品去
发
这样才行
你看这些看来都是
买家非常多的那种
才行
所以说你要按照这种思路去选
我一般的话会建议如果是你想要旋盘量多的话选这个
如果是你想要订单或者是说你的
做的是RTS的话就选
热销的这个
板块
评论的话你就选这个
评论板块
而且这个评论板块你可以进去看
客户都评论哪些他在意的哪些点
这个有助于我们去做详评页的内部
布局
呈现一些客户想看到
希望解决
他痛点的问题
呈现一些解决方案给他
那么你这个
单品的转化可能就会有一定的提倡
那么接下来
你可以按照我这种方法
灵活的
去应用
一定要去
结合你的品类
去进行一个
应用
一定要找
同行的时候
多一点
同时呢
一定要做
差异化
就按照这个思路去做
一到五个标题
如果你有更多产品要发
可以做十个以上
发完之后
如果你有预算允许
那么你可以直接进行一个推广
推广选什么推广方式呢
选新品加速
就可以了
就按照这个思路
去不断的去
应用
是把这个方法
内化成你自己了
好了,这节课我们就讲到这里,下节课我们继续讲
第三种
关于
报款标题的组合方法